we're not going to trade jaylen ya
notice other GM's have said that then
they turned around and trade well yeah
but that's not our intention and that's
not that's how we when you have a player
that's one of the top at his position
it's hard to replace that player he took
the bait because I keep thinking of Rick
Spielman it's been six years now since
he said we have no intent to trade percy
harvin
and they traded him so when i that other
we that's not our intention intention is
the magic word because that's not our
intention okay
yeah but intention changes and if
somebody calls them up and offers them a
significant haul of picks and/or players
for Jalen Ramsey well you know what now
we do intend to treat yeah that's right
but Jalen Ramsey is the type of player
that in the in the trade asset world I
think a command
Khaleel Mac you know ish type trade
offers where yeah you don't trade them
unless you get like two first-round
picks on the board Jalen Ramsey is a
special special talent and I think what
we're seeing in the NFL to cornerback
again is back in vogue you need to have
good corners look at the Super Bowl
champions look at the other team in the
Super Bowl they had two good corners but
New England you have to this day and age
in the NFL with all the advanced
offenses right Mike and the bunches and
the picks and plays like that there's
certain downs on third and four third
and five you got to play man-to-man you
can't play zone the Tom Brady's of the
worlds the Patrick mahomes you play zone
on third and four they're gonna find a
little hole in the zone and just go BAM
there you go first down let's move the
chains Jalen Ramsey the world can match
up with the Tyree kills and all the
other good receivers to go okay you want
to try to jam this third and fourth row
in there well I'm gonna be all over him
I might intercept it or bath the ball in
the air and somebody else does it that's
how special no player is I would be
shocked if they tried to trade them who
are the guys I know now who are the guys
that you would consider untradable
though Patrick mahomes yes Shawn watts
sure after that and I'm talking about no
offer there's nothing you would do and
you can go three drafts out I mean if
you go three first-round picks okay I
can throw other stuff on top of it you
can go three first-round picks three
second-round picks you put players on
there so you could ultimately put
together a huge package right is there
anyone out there other than my homes and
Watson's that you would say is on trade
well Matt Casey just got in my ear too
and said
Donald are you supposed to take them
don't act like that I'm giving them
credit boy question I wanted to give him
credit all right I would have got there
eventually but it was very good that he
said that to me Aaron Donald certainly
falls into that category I mean at this
point in their careers Heisei qualms
berkeley is still in that category i
think that was because oh you're crazy
he is - he's he's the best running back
in football right now hey what if
Patrick's a quark but it is a short list
to your to your point and now you got me
sitting here thinking I'm pulling up the
team's looking at sorry sorry but it is
a very short list to your point
I mean Jalen Ramsey you can't say he's
untradable no it would be a package that
the Jaguars would have to say what we're
taking this to first-round picks
we're taking it yeah I think so I mean I
very rare that anybody is just totally
untradable unless he's a franchise
quarterback or really just a franchise
pass rusher defensive lineman disrupter
I think those two positions probably go
up another category or two as far as you
know trade you know what do I want to
say trade availability or what you have
to trade to get them it's gonna take
something truly truly special in
Oakland's case I don't think they ever
won the trade khalil Mac I think Oakland
was in a very tough spot because I don't
think their team and their owner could
pay Khalil Mak what he wanted to get in
pure cash and that's why they had to
abandon ship well they miss they miss
played the situation with Khalil Mack
and they waited too long and it blew up
in their faces when when Aaron Donald
signed his contract and it became
obvious what it was going to cost to
keep Khalil Mack around yeah that's why
the next day they traded Russell
Wilson's probably in that category right
I don't I don't circumstances drive that
right because when you consider that
Russell Wilson now is in the final URIs
contract and next year the franchise tag
for MB 31 million the year after that be
37 million the year after that it's a 44
percent raise it's over 50 million yeah
the Seahawks at some point may say you
know what do we want to spend this kind
of money on the guy or do we just move
on yeah and and so that yeah if you get
a good offer for maybe you do it
wouldn't
would show good shot right now next year
would be different they franchise tag
them and trade him that's a different
scenario hands in there and say this guy
won't accept our offers he doesn't want
to be here what can we do
I mean Russell Wilson is another one
just like I said with Jalen Ramsay I
mean just get it done now start doing it
there's a hell of a PR fight that would
be looming right if there would be a
divorce between the Seahawks and Russell
well sighs read cuz Wilson's gonna act
like I hey I'm just doing my thing right
you actually say hey blame him not us we
want to keep right we want to pay him
he's gonna say I took a nice front team
friendly deal the last time let me give
you an example when Eli Manning's last
contract came up yeah the way that his
franchise tag was working out if you did
the formula it would have made him the
highest-paid player in football that's
just the way the formula worked for the
franchise track so the Giants start
leaking Eli Manning wants to be the
highest-paid player in football and that
kind of shouted him down to take less
than what the franchise tag formula
would have give him so that those games
will get played if definitely to that
point between the Seahawks and Russell
was
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports